quand le soleil est là les brocantes et
vide-greniers ne sont jamais loin
exemple ce week-end à saint pierre des
corps avec le tout premier événement
organisé par la banque alimentaire
plaisir retrouvé des chineurs et des
exposants après plusieurs mois sous
cloche
romain des lui il s'y est rendu des
tréteaux une planche lambda ou une table
à tapisser des jouets des peluches des
vêtements quelques objets anciens aussi
c'est le retour des brocantes un moment
très attendu pour les vendeurs du
dimanche avec impatience avec impatience
ce besoin de parler avec les clients ce
besoin de revoir déjà des collègues qui
font ce métier là depuis quelques années
moi je suis nouveau dans le milieu ça
fait une quinzaine d'années que j'y suis
je débute encore j'ai encore des choses
à apprendre mais c'est vrai que le fait
de retrouver des clients que je connais
ma clientèle rien que ça m'a beaucoup
manqué et c'est vrai que les brocantes
c'est extraordinaire pour ça sur les 160
exposants céline hérité d'un super
emplacement à une intersection son
rythme de croisière habituellement ces
deux brocantes par an pour renouveler
des jouets des enfants
après un an et demi de disette la
vendeuse amateurs fait un retour
fracassant pratiquement tout vendu ce
matin un monde super
franchement on s'attendait pas à autant
de monde mais toulon étaient super
contents de se revoir et de refaire des
brocantes franchement impeccable sous le
soleil exactement la rue des grands
mortier à saint-pierre s'anime grâce à
la première brocante de la banque
alimentaire
l'association qui a trouvé là un moyen
de financement
d'habitude la banque alimentaire
participer à des événements qui faisait
à peu de rentrées d'argent mais là avec
le co vider les confinements on a pas on
n'a pas eu tous ces événements donc j'ai
eu l'idée de lancer ce vide greniers et
puis on voit que c'est une véritable
réussite on a beaucoup de monde aussi
bien en exposant camp visiteur on a une
superbe météo par rapport à il ya vu de
dix jours donc on est on est hyper
content de cette journée les vide
greniers sont autorisés depuis la mi mai
pourvu que les lieux d'accueil
conviennent à la préfecture les chineurs
les vendeurs host espérait que la saison
des brocantes a bel et bien commencé